I what do you get from video games in
general is there is there for you for
you person I mean it's I don't know it's
uh it calms my mind I mean you sort of
killing the demons in a video game calms
the demons in my
mind yeah if you play a tough video game
you can get into like a state of flow
which is very enjoyable um and uh but
the
admittedly it needs to be not too easy
not too hard um kind of in the goldilock
zone um and I guess you generally want
to feel like you're progressing in the
game
so um a good video and and there's also
beautiful art um engaging
storylines um and it's a it's like an
amazing puzzle to solve I think and so
it's like solving the puzzle Elder ring
the greatest game of all time I still
haven't played it but you it's alen ring
is definitely a candidate for best game
ever top five for sure I think I've been
scared how hard it is or how hard I hear
it is so but it is beautiful alen ring
is feels like it's designed by an
alien um there's a theme to this
discussion in what way it's it's it's so
unusual it's incredibly creative and the
art is
stunning I recommend playing it on a on
a big resolution
P Dynamic R TV even doesn't need to be a
monitor just uh the art is incredible
it's so
beautiful and and it's it's so
unusual
um and each of those top boss battles is
unique like it's like a unique puzzle to
solve each one's different um and the
strategy you use to solve one battle is
different from another battle that's
said you said Druid an eternal against
Uber Lilith is the hardest boss battle
you've ever correct that is currently
the the and I've I've played a lot of
video games because it's my primary
recreational activity yes
um
and
yes beating hatred in the internal realm
yeah is the hardest boss
battle in life and in the video game